it's not for morning rounds our look at
the medical news of the week scientists
may have made a major breakthrough in
the fight against breast cancer in a
study published this week in the nature
Journal researchers from the University
of Southern California and Yale
University were able to teach a computer
to better identify the nature of breast
tumors the hope is it'll help doctors
speed up diagnosis and open up treatment
to more people worldwide dr. David agus
is a CBS News medical contributor and
the lead author on this study he's here
to tell us more about it David good
morning morning Anthony tell us about
the findings so we had a hypothesis that
how the cells the breast cancer cells
are arranged on a slide was a reflection
of the biology and the human eye is good
at seeing patterns but computers machine
learning AI is so much better at that so
we took breast cancer half of them had
an on switch called estrogen receptor
and half didn't and the computer could
pick them out so right now if you're a
woman with breast cancer you have a
biopsy they have to stain that a couple
weeks later they tell you the results
and they tell you your treatment the
beauty now is that literally you can
scan this slide in and instantaneously
know how to treat it costs are down time
is down think of it for third world
medicine literate could be done
overnight you could see in the picture
here you know on the right this is
digital this is done with a computer
identifying which are the cells versus
doing a long molecular process to
identify them so ai is going to
transform how we diagnose and how we
treat cancer you've called this the
beginning of a revolution is that
because the computers are learning or is
there something that this might unlock
as far as other treatment options well
right now it's saying which of the genes
on and off but going forward it's gonna
say who's gonna respond to what drug so
it's all there that information now we
can lock it and the main thing is the
computing power we have today is
staggering that cell phone is what a
supercomputer was a decade ago now it's
being unleashed to basically help us
fight cancer and so the tech world the
Silicon Valley progress is helping us in
our field treat patients better to live
better and live longer it's very
exciting
one of the big issues with
cancer detection is the frequency of all
those pop false positives so will this
new technology will it will it reduce
that number so the idea is yeah when you
get a mammogram there's something there
and they said oh my gosh we got to do a
biopsy and some of them turn out not to
be breast cancer a lot of stress a lot
of procedures are needed to be doing so
that same concept of using machine
learning or artificial intelligence on a
mammogram can be done I mean humans are
good at pattern recognition computers
are better so this is going to be an
explosion in our field that are really
going to change how we treat men and
women with cancer fantastic news for
people going forward our next topic we
hear a lot about expanding access to
healthcare but that may actually not be
enough a new report in The Lancet this
week looked at the impact of healthcare
quality on mortality rates the study
covered a two-year period it estimates
that in low and middle income countries
five million people die every year
because of poor quality healthcare and
that's more than 3.6 million people in
those countries who die from not having
healthcare access so some are getting
access but it doesn't help
there was also an editorial arguing that
increasing access to health insurance
isn't enough how do you explain all of
this so the first is and I think this is
really important is why we should care
is that Council on Foreign Relations did
a report two years ago showing that if
non communicable diseases heart disease
and cancer or treat a better in Africa
it helps our economy and what we're
seeing in this study is really important
in that it's not just access to care
it's doing it right so it's not just
what you do it's how you do it education
and training both at the patient and the
physician level are critical especially
in developing countries and so we can't
just give aid we have to make sure they
do the right thing and get these
diseases treated because we can prevent
and delay heart disease cancer and some
infectious disease in these countries
and we're not doing it well enough what
other solutions are possible well you
know if you look at it today is that
that computer that computer can also be
involved in treatment we can use it to
say hey did you do X and y and z and
have a checklist and so those checklists
can actually help us treat disease
better so instead of just sending the
pill or sending the vaccine let's put it
in a checklist and figure out ways to
actually do the right thing in the
patient so they can live longer better
in these developing countries which in
the long run again helps us because
everyone says why does it matter to me
it matters to us I could not do anything
without my checklist a really good point
finally this morning a plea for plain
English you may not always understand
everything your doctor tells you well
this week a Royal Medical Academy in
Britain urged doctors to summarize in
simple plain English a patient's visit
to the office and the recommended
treatments for their condition or
illness for example the guidelines say
that while chronic means a long-standing
condition many patients think it just
means bad so doctors were urged not to
use it
I totally disagree I mean this is gonna
hurt our ego like you wouldn't my
business about multi-syllable words
belong more important and smart